[Music]
hi it's Michelle from loudmouth and
beauty signs here your favorite skincare
science node whose name starts with M
and ends in a shelf I have a PhD in
chemistry and I love talking about the
science behind beauty products today I'm
teaming up with Panasonic to talk about
their new skincare tools I'm going to be
talking about what they do the science
behind how they work and how I've been
incorporating them into my skincare
routine the EHS c-65 microphone facial
cleanser and the EHS tea 63 ionic facial
cleanser in turn on my routine is pretty
straightforward and basic but I've been
really enjoying how well these tools
work with my routine so the first home
skincare products from Panasonic which
is a Japanese company and they're
inspired by the whole Japanese skincare
ritual culture these work with any
skincare products and they're designed
to bump up the effectiveness and the
absorption of the products into your
skin I'm gonna start with an overview of
each tool and the science behind how
they work and then I'm going to show you
how I use them in my routine there's a
link in the description below if you
want to find out more about how to
incorporate them into different routines
that don't have the same steps as my
routine let's start with the microphone
facial cleanser this has a recommended
retail price of 229 Australian dollars
which is comparable with a lot of other
electronic cleansing tools on the market
it's a four in one tool and it has a
rotating head which has different
attachments that you can put on it it
also has a heated makeup removal plate
on the other end this tool comes with a
cleansing brush but you don't have to
use it as a cleansing brush which is
important because if you know how I feel
about cleansing brushes you know I think
they shouldn't be used every day and a
lot of closing brush companies encourage
you to use them every day and maybe
twice a day with brushes that have
really stiff bristles in my opinion and
in my experience cleansing twice a day
with a cleansing brush is only
appropriate for a really small section
of the population I know a lot of people
who end up over exfoliating with
cleansing brushes if you use it too
regularly you can end up with rashes
ruskin and stinging skin you're taking
off the top layer of your stratum
corneum
this is the layer of dead skin cells on
top of your skin there's about 15 to 20
layers and they're meant to be there to
protect the rest of your skin from being
exposed I was a moderator on a skin care
firm for a bit over four years and it
was really common to see new members
come in talking about how they've been
using a cleansing brush too hard and too
often because the scrubbing feels really
good the problem is that the foam from
the cleansing brush is really handy and
you probably need to wash your face
every day with cleanser if you wear
sunscreen and makeup so it's really easy
to just keep using the cleansing brush
way more than you should
this device ends up getting around this
problem by having a separate foaming
mechanism in the middle of the tool and
the main attachment is actually this
rollerball attachment and these balls
roll over your skin in a massaging
motion there's pretty much no
exfoliation and the springs stop it from
pressing into your skin too hard there's
still an included brush attachment if
you want to exfoliate your skin
it's got extremely soft bristles as the
default brush which I'm a big fan of you
can see how soft the bristles are so
they Bend even under its own weight I
also really like that the instructions
tell you how to use it and what pressure
to use they tell you to use it with such
light pressure that the bristles don't
Bend and they recommend that you start
using once a week and stop if you feel
any irritation which i think is an
important warning there's also the pore
focus brush which has these little
silicon fingers so you're meant to use
this to dislodge blackheads and the
so-called sebaceous filaments which is
really just gunk in your pores there are
some extra add-on brushes that you can
buy as well there's the normal brush
which has slightly firmer bristles I
think they're the same bristles but
because they're a bit shorter they're a
little bit firmer when you press down
and there's also an exfoliation brush
which has silicone fingers in between
the bristles which are pretty much the
same as the normal brush bristles I'm
really impressed by how soft these
bristles are there are lots softer than
your standard normal cleansing brushes
the best thing about this tool is that
it produces a whole bunch of foam so
guess foam out of cleansers that usually
don't throw em up too much to begin with
there's two heat settings on the warm
makeup removing plate there's a low
setting which is 43 degrees Celsius and
a high heat setting which is 48 degrees
Celsius
I try not to use hot water on my skin so
I was actually a bit worried that this
plate might be true
much for me it might cause me some
irritation but I found that it's
actually not that hot it's actually a
really comfortable soothing temperature
even on the high setting
it feels nowhere near as hot as sticking
your face under the showerhead the
second device is the eh s T 63 ionic
cleansing and toning device this is
designed for cycles of three minutes of
cleansing moisturizing and brightening
this is a microcurrent device that's a
bit unusual because it's based on
something called iontophoresis
iontophoresis is when a really low
current is passed through your skin and
studies have found that there's better
skin hydration and better skin delivery
of a lot of active ingredients into your
skin there have been a few studies done
on iontophoresis and the delivery of
different skincare ingredients including
threatenin which is a form of vitamin A
estrogen vitamin E and a few different
forms of vitamin C including ascorbic
acid and magnesium ascorbic phosphate
the clinical studies focused on treating
acne scars and pigmentation
iontophoresis is used in a lot of
skincare clinics but this is an at-home
device and I tested the current that
this uses the high current uses 19 micro
amps over this area researchers
recommend an absolute maximum of 500
microamps per square centimeter even
when you're trying to get substances way
deeper into your skin at higher currents
there's also more discomfort as well and
I had no discomfort with this one
researchers aren't a hundred percent
clear how iontophoresis works it seems
to be a combination of the electrodes
repelling various ions through your skin
and the electrical current disturbing
skin temporarily for better penetration
and this is highest through water called
diffusion shunts which are places in
your skin where diffusion happens better
so things like paws hair follicles
sebaceous ducts and sweat ducts skin
disturbance sounds a bit scary but with
iontophoresis it doesn't seem to last
very long and it doesn't seem to be the
usual type of disturbance either so for
example trans epidermal water loss which
is when water evaporates through your
skin doesn't seem to decrease when you
are using iontophoresis so there's one
electrode here which goes on your face
and one electrode here which you hold in
your hand so depending on which mode
you're using the
current will either run from the plate
into your face through your skin up to
your arm and the back of the device
that's in Brighton mode when you're
using the moisturize or massage modes it
actually runs backwards so the current
runs from this play into your hand along
your skin and then back out through your
face and the reason why the current runs
in two different ways is because of the
two main ways that iontophoresis works
firstly there's electro repulsion also
known as electrophoresis this is based
on the fact that the same charge will
repel the same charge so for example a
negative charge will repel a negative
charge when this little tool is in
brighton mode the negative plate is this
plate here that's going to turn into the
cathode the important part of vitamin C
is the negatively charged part the
ascorbate iron and so the negative
cathode is going to repel it and push it
deeper into your skin the other way that
iontophoresis works is through what's
called electro osmosis at normal skin pH
which is somewhere around five human
skin actually has a slight negative
charge things don't like just being
negatively charged so as well as your
skin there's going to be some positive
ions like sodium which is going to be
sitting there neutralizing this negative
charge so that overall you end up with
no charge your skin can't move very much
because it's kind of stuck in place but
these positive ions called cations can
move so if you have your device on your
skin and this end is positive those
positively charged ions are going to go
into your skin
they're also attached to water and so it
takes the water with it and this leads
to greater skin hydration as it's taking
the water it can also take other things
as well so they kind of get caught up in
the flow so that's the reason why the
direction of the current flow will
change depending on the mode there's a
cleanse mode which gets rid of anything
that's remaining on your skin after
cleansing this is more like a toning
step so you'll be using this with toner
and a cotton pad this prepares your skin
for better absorption of whatever
ingredients you're going to put on
afterwards there's also the moisturize
mode which hydrates the skin using the
mode where this end is positive this
mode uses again a cotton pad or you can
use it over a sheet mask as well then
there's the brighter mode which is where
this
that's on your face is negatively
charged and so you can push the
negatively charged ingredients into your
skin you'll be using this with a serum
or a cream that contains vitamin C
finally there's also the warm rythm
massage mode there's two different modes
for this so mode number one sounds like
this I'm gonna lean down to the
microphone mode two each mode has
different temperatures there's cold warm
and room-temperature and there's also
different iron levels as well so there's
low medium high when you've got a
circuit going to triangular head vibrate
so you know whether or not that flow is
working the scientific studies weren't
performed on this specific tool but
manufacturer studies found that it
increased active ingredient delivery by
40 percent and it helped cleanse the
skin more by 60 percent I personally
don't use every step every night but I
found that you can actually finish it in
15 minutes if you do all of the steps
and I think because these tools make
your products more effective it ends up
being a lot faster on different days
I'll pick and choose the steps that I
use depending on what I feel like my
skin needs that particular night all
right so I'm gonna show you what my
routine looks like when I'm using these
tools I've already removed my eye makeup
and my lipstick using a separate makeup
remover because I don't like using my
cleansing oil on those areas I use the
double cleanse at the beginning of my
skincare routine this is really popular
in Asian skin care routines like the
ones used in Korean and Japanese
skincare and it's really good for people
with dehydration prone skin instead of
using one harsh cleanser you use two
gentle cleansers that can act in
slightly different ways and so you still
end up with a really thorough clean but
without all that irritation so start
with the cleansing oil I'm using liji
Homs life pure cleansing oil I use it
with the warm makeup removing plate it
takes about 30 seconds to warm it up
using a really small amount of heat in
your cleansing is good
because while it doesn't open up your
pores it does help soften the oil inside
your pores and help it flow out more
easily it's also good for helping soften
your makeup so again it comes off more
easily it's a lot better
then trying to target your skin it's
important that the heat you use isn't
too hot otherwise it can irritate your
skin and this temperature is quite nice
it feels a bit like I'm using maybe my
hand after I've warmed it under a shower
this is on the low setting at the moment
even on the high setting it's really
comfortable the next step is massage
cleansing and this trade only takes
about a minute I usually do this in the
shower this device is waterproof I've
got the roller massage head on I use the
soft brush about once a week with
minimal pressure and I use the silicon
portal again once a week after I've used
phone there's a bit of a misconception
that all foaming cleansers are bad a lot
of low foaming cleansers are quite
gentle because they contain a lot less
surfactants but there's better
technology these days which makes high
phone out of not very harsh ingredients
there's actually a study that found that
a low foaming cleanser was actually more
drying to skin then a high foaming
cleanser that had lots of oils and
emollients in it I'm using Paula's
Choice hydrating gel to cream
cleanser.you pour the cleanser in you
need to pull water into the middle of
this thing they've got a convenient
measuring tool that comes as the cap
right a button on the soft setting and
it's recommended that you move this tool
in these stripes there's actually a lot
of foam coming out this tool pauses
every 20 seconds to tell you to move to
the next part
so you're meant to use the 20 seconds on
this side 20 seconds on this side and 20
seconds on your forehead but I find that
it's actually done and way less than
that so I only really use the Perth out
20 seconds you can also use this on your
body which is really great in the shower
and you can also use the massage roller
head to spread cream on your face as
well
for training I use the ionic device and
you use it with a cotton pad so you put
the cotton pad over the triangle and
then there's this ring which goes on top
you soak up with whatever toner you want
I'm using Claire's supple preparation
unscented toner which I'm almost out of
it's cleanse mode I'm using medium iron
and I'm going for room temperature so
mixer pulsing sound and this step gets
rid of any leftover Church on your skin
this step also hydrates your skin if
your skin's well hydrated then it tends
to absorb your skin care products much
more efficiently and you can actually
see that I've gotten some dirt out gross
the next step is sheet masking a lot of
people use the sheet mask at the end of
their routine but I like using it at
this stage to just hydrate my skin a bit
more I'm using the real barrier aqua
soothing and pill masks my biggest issue
with sheet masks is that I don't like
sitting around waiting for it to be done
so I really like how this tool speeds up
how quickly the sheet mask works so this
time I'm using the moisturize mode again
I'm using medium and I'm going to be
using room temperature
so math says 10 to 20 minutes but after
about three minutes using the tool I'm
done with it so the next step is
brightening I currently have a nasty
pimple here so what I'm doing is I'm
putting a bit of resist advanced pore
refining treatment which is full percent
PHA from Paula's choice on that little
pimple which is threatening to turn into
a big pimple
die-die
and I'm going to be using skin diva 20%
vitamin C plus E Plus for Ehrlich serum
vitamin C is a really good skin care
ingredient because it asks to fade
pigment and it's a really good
antioxidant as well which means it
quenches the free radicals in your skin
which can cause lots of skin damage I've
got another video which is about
antioxidants which I've linked in the
description I have a lot of problems
with pigment because I'm Asian and
Asians are really good at producing
pigment as you can tell from my amazing
hair the problem with vitamin C is that
it's really bad at getting through your
skin and so pushing it through
iontophoresis is a really good way of
getting it into your skin deeper
if your serums all absorb then you'll
find that the tool doesn't glider of
your skin as smoothly and the current
can drop a bit so I like to use a
thermal water which is from event to
Reve wet my skin if that happens
so now I'm up to my final two steps
which are eye cream and moisturizer the
eye cream I'm using is one from jelly
kits the hope of recovery signature eye
cream with my eye creams are not really
looking for actives I just spread
whatever active serum I have up to the
eye region and I'm selecting the massage
mode and I'm using it on warm
temperature
so I'm doing this rolling motion so that
I don't tug at the delicate skin around
my eyes now the final step is
moisturizing so again I'm going to be
using massage mode today I'm using alpha
H essential hydration cream and the
thing I like most about this is that it
has a pump chop so pump a bit out onto
the top
I add some zelans powdi I find that this
is really nice for calming down
sensitive skin now I'm using the first
massage mode on warm temperature and I'm
going to press it in
it's a really nice soothing massage
and I'm done if you want a bit more info
on how you can use it in your routine if
you have steps that aren't in my routine
you can click on the link and you'll see
what Panasonic's recommendations are I
hope you enjoyed this video if you liked
it please click the thumbs up and
subscribe to my channel thank you so
much to Panasonic for collaborating with
me on this project for more skincare
tips you can check me out on lab mufin
beauty science on instagram and you can
check out my blog if you're interested
in learning more about the science
behind beauty products see you next time
you